so you say you're you're honest with
your kids
yeah
almost 100 of the night
like without fail almost 100 of the time
they know you're addicted to opiates
oh yeah
for pretty much the entire time that
I've been using them they know that
that I've been using and my kids are
pretty smart
um
which is nice it's great to have kids
that are so intelligent you know it's a
blessing it'll be great for their
teachers but it's also a curse because
they're pretty they're very astute they
can pick up on things as soon as they
picked up on some changes they asked me
and I you know I can't
I don't feel good about lying to them
[Music]
the way I look at it the truth comes out
in the end
and um
you know like I said before that I am
I I've I've hurt people that love me
um people that I didn't really think
care too much about me
um
and I've I've learned by dragging
everybody through this you know with me
alongside me
um how much they really do
you know care for me and what they'd be
willing to do for me and they've all
suffered so much because they just
happen to love me that like I refuse to
I refuse to do any more damage to them
I'm not gonna
um
I'm not gonna have them get a phone call
one day that says you know I'm gone and
and
and have them be not only blindsided by
my loss but the fact that I even had a
problem you know that I was even at risk
of anything because they didn't even
know I was using like I gotta I gotta
honor them and respect them by
by answering their questions if they ask
me if they want to know they're ready to
know
how long you've been addicted
gosh it's been
wow it's been three years now actually
to the exact month three years so you
didn't you didn't start like many two as
a teenager or anything like that
no not not my jarg of choice
which is is heroin I'm an opiate addict
um I guess I've always been an opiate
from the way it's described or the way
they explain it to me you know all the
professionals it's like a sleeper you
know and uh I just I guess I just woke
it up you know three years ago but is it
in your family
oh Addiction in general yeah
I
foreign I lost my brother
to this addiction addiction to this drug
oh really
um six years ago
in March six years ago
and anyone
in your parental side
um addicted oh yeah but you know
fortunately
we haven't lost anybody else
but you know my parents both um I mean
my mom is an alcoholic
oh she used to do a really good job of
uh being a productive alcoholic or how
do they say it's
functioning alcoholic not So Much
Anymore my father is recovered or
recovering alcoholic
I'm really proud of him actually
he won't have a beer now he quit smoking
cigarettes and everything so
um just about actually know every single
one of us in my immediate family that I
grew up with
we're we're addicts we've been addicted
so do you do you feel shame in your
situation or do you see it as something
you just inherited from your family
both
have you OD'd the life
yeah
yeah I don't actually I don't I don't
know how many times
at least 10.
um at least 10.
I explained to those that are watching
like how you can OD 10 times and not
decide to quit
I'm sure you're very sensible
as as most of the people I interview are
but it's it's much bigger than that
I can't explain it I can't explain it
uh
so somebody who
um somebody who I consider
a family member somebody who has been in
my life a long time and and was very
close friends with my little brother
before he passed explained it the best
I've heard it so far
and um I was talking about
going to treatment and I really thought
this time was going to be the time that
I went
and
um
you know my my mother and my boyfriend
were on my case about it like you need
to go you need to go and you know it'll
be free and install you know it's set up
for you and just listen to the lady from
the county it'll be fine and man I just
was so caught on the fact of I didn't
want to I was scared to go be alone
I didn't want to go away and go check
into inpatient treatment
um I was afraid of the ways that life
would move on and change without me
while I was away
for a long time I didn't want to be
separated from my boyfriend
even though the longer I stayed out here
the farther apart we grew and
the more I was actually separated from
him in fact anyway because he just
wouldn't be around me
um he didn't want to see me like them
so you know I was telling my friend like
I didn't want to go and I can just do I
just gotta find a good outpatient if I
could just find a good Outpatient Clinic
then I mean I'm all for it I just
Somebody's gotta help me do that and and
my friend just like
totally just like Snapped me into
reality
and he said
you know
you should really hear yourself
that's just your addiction talking
you really can't trust your thoughts
right now
you're honestly gonna sit here and tell
me you think you don't need inpatient
treatment
he said honey you're just trying to set
it up to where you can
please the family and go do what
everyone's asking of you but still be
able to use drugs while you're in
treatment
and I was like huh
huh
you can I didn't know that's what I was
doing I really I didn't I was it wasn't
like a conscious thing but when he put
it to me like that
I was like you're right that's what I'm
doing I'm I'm I'm I'm making a
contingency plan it's a just in case
that way I could still use you know I
mean just in case like I'm not feeling
it just in case I'm not ready
and he told me
you know it's like um
a parasite
it takes over it gets in your brain
and it just [__] up your thought can I
say that yeah it [__] up your thoughts
and you can't even trust yourself as a
matter of fact you're the person you
you're the last person you should trust
right now
honey throw all that [__] out and you
need to just listen just go and just
surrender
this person also happened to be one of
my dealers
so you know if I really if I was really
gonna go get the [__] I mean he was
gonna sell it to me
he didn't like that I was doing it but
you know he was like man
I wish you would stop but
I'd rather you come get it from me
what are you doing before you got
addicted because you're you're how old
are you
I'm 40. I just turned 40. and you got
addicted at 37.
yeah what was that all about
um
yeah
and it's kind of like getting a divorce
it's like it's not any one thing that
makes you
do it right
um
so I actually when I started using
heroin
um I mean I wasn't using uh I wasn't
popping Vicodins or using a lot of
people were like I heard smoking blues
or whatever they were calling him at the
time and I wasn't using any kind of
other opiates leading up to it
and I didn't know anybody
who was using heroin
I'd never been around heroin users
before
yeah I know I see that you're you're
like what
so
I actively seeked out
this drug
um I had some things that had happened
in over a period of about two years
it just seemed like one thing after the
other after the other other other
and it just was built up and it was so
it was all just laying on me so heavy
um and my support system had totally
changed because a couple of the things
that happened were
you know the breakup of my family
um the end of my marriage of 22 years
um the
the realization that my
my children my three daughters were not
ever going to be living in the same home
with me again
needing me to make them a breakfast or
braid their hair after the bath you know
like that
all that was gone and and those people
that I went to when I needed support or
comfort
they weren't there
anymore
not that they wouldn't have been there
for me but they weren't in my day-to-day
life
and like
I didn't know how to cope with that or
the other things that were happening
um they were just too much for me and I
was hurting I just was hurting so bad
I'm still hurting so bad
would you say that mental health is what
was behind your
addiction let's say pain you know pain
yeah if that's and that's immense mental
health right you know whether or not you
are
a lot of people hear mental health and
they think like oh crazy or you know I
mean your stress of life and right and
we all have struggles dealing with our
mental health you know and that's what
it was for me is I just it I I didn't
know how to cope anymore
um I still am trying to accept
and come to terms with the fact that my
brothers has died
like [__] getting on with figuring out
how to grieve him like I'm not even I
haven't even really accepted it yeah you
know
and that was just one of the number of
things so it just was a lot and I
decided I needed to escape from this
and I remembered my brother telling me
one time you know I was begging him
asking him please you just leave this
[__] alone
um I don't get what it is you know like
why does that have such a hold on you
like don't you love us don't you see
like we love you so much we just want
you back
what is it
about this [__] that you just can't just
let go and come home like why is it
controlling you
and he said to me that
it was so much nicer
being Comfortably Numb
than having to
hurt all day every day
from from everything that
he carried around with him you know and
boy
I did not forget that so you chose to
pick up fentanyl after your brother died
from it I picked up heroin yeah um a
fentanyl is a that's a that's a very new
development for me
but yeah I did I remember him saying
that and I and I went out and I actively
seeked out the heroine at odds I'm
getting it first because I you know I'm
like upper middle class Suburban you
know white soccer mom looking lady at
the time and
I was asking people in the hood where I
hadn't lived for very long and
they were like man get out of here you
look like the police and it took a
little bit but I figured out what kind
of lingo to use and what kind of
language you know
relax them and before long it was maybe
a few days of trying and I had a bag of
heroin and literally had to ask somebody
how to use it
and I started by smoking it
and yeah that was about three years ago
and about
two months ago
a little less Maybe
um I found myself unable to find heroin
like I did
at home in Sacramento I've been down
here in downtown L.A now about two
months
and um
the few times that I have been able to
find heroin it was too expensive
and what is readily available what is
just like rampant down here like it's
like everybody seems to be using
Fentanyl
so
I mean of course I had a choice
but it didn't feel like I had much of a
choice you know it's like be sick or do
study and so I've been using Fentanyl
for
about six or seven weeks now
what does your family think of you
or do they understand
given their
history
scared to know what they think of me
really
I mean I think if I asked them they
would talk a lot about their love for me
and how they desire for
our relationships to be repaired
and how they want
me to have a prosperous you know
happy life
but um
I I'm scared to hear what they might
tell somebody else if somebody else
asked about me
because putting the addict in shame
pretty much ensures that they're going
to stay right where they're at right
oh it just gets a little bit more
complicated too because
I know we started out this interview
with me telling you I'm I'm honest with
my kids like my kids know I'm a drug
addict and they know you know
um because
like almost 100 of the time I am honest
with them always
but um perks for me coming down to
downtown L.A coming down to La the
Greater Los Angeles area in the first
place
was to get out
of Sacramento to get away from the
people and the places and the things
that I associated with my addiction that
made it easy for me to live that out and
stay in that lifestyle
um
and
I came to go to treatment
and I like
didn't have the heart to
tell everybody that um
I'm not a treatment yet
so
you know nobody's perfect
and um that's so that's the big that's
the big fit that's the big fit right now
you came down here to go to I came down
to go to treatment and I've not been in
treatment
and my family believes
um
it's crazy like because I value on being
honest to them so much and I really do
but damn it I hate hearing the
disappointment in their voices I hate
hearing how much they worry about me
and
I I knew that
they wanted me to come to treatment and
that they knew that's why I came down
here and I didn't want to tell them that
once I got down here
that I wasn't in treatment
like they believed and hoped
so
what's your biggest fear
it's not even dying
dying is not my biggest fear
welcome
uh kind of it is it's
um
it's devastating my daughters
somehow in some way
so that they
in turn become
like me and they feel irrevocably broken
and then they
wind up living out
the same type of mistakes and suffering
the same path that I have
I'm I'm not scared to die you know
they're I won't lie I've I've tried to
take my own life
um
I'm I'm done with suffering I mean I'm
tired
I might even you know I'd probably even
welcome it at this point if it weren't
for those girls
because I that's my biggest fear because
I'm terrified
to hurt them anymore
like
is a crazy disease it really is a crazy
disease because
um I I
like to think of myself as a highly
intelligent person
um
I'm I'm decently educated I'm pretty
emotionally intelligent I'm insightful I
pick up on people's energies and I can
read the vibe of a room you know pretty
well and
um and I know what type of actions and
decisions lead to what type of outcomes
and what helps you reach goals and what
you know what hinders that process and
I'll be damned if I just can't seem to
just [__] get on board and do the
right [__]
to bring me
the outcome that I desire
it's like there's a disconnect
and you know I I don't know how better
to
to look at it or describe it then then
my friend did that time to me which is
man like I just can't trust my own
judgment or my own thoughts you know
there's a disconnect I can't explain why
it's there where it came from but I just
know that because of it
I can't be the one being in charge of
making healthy decisions you know
I haven't been able to do it yet you
know
yeah
I guess I guess they're gonna watch this
too my my daughters
they're old enough my my kids are 24
19 or 16 years old
and at their ages
were you there to raise them for most of
their lives yes most of their lives yes
yeah
that was that kind of broke my heart too
because that was one of the things that
um
I still haven't been able to figure out
how to like just swallow that pill and
come to terms with that that
the last you know five years or so
of their
childhoods at home
where they should have been with me
where their father or both of us that I
wasn't there you know
you're an unusual case because most
people make it to
their late 30s and
don't get caught up in this this stuff
yeah it is a little odd though right it
is that I would
um
find myself having these problems so
late in my life
I guess you know it's not that I never
um
experienced
troubles or not that I've never
um
dabbled with substances or anything like
that but
um
I only went so far with it you know and
it was a very recreational
way the things that I did try
they didn't stay
you know in my life for long and I
didn't you know become like a hardcore
user
I mean you wouldn't have caught me using
meals for anything
um back in the day you know before the
last three years and
you certainly you know wouldn't have
seen me using anything
all day every day or for a stretch of
you know a couple of years it was just
kind of like here and there it was
really it was for it was for party it
was for fun fun you know
um and when it got to be too much or
when I felt like it started affecting
[__] you know in my life or things
around me like
I would just you know kicked to the curb
and you know just get back to business
you know
and uh it's not easy to do that this
stuff it's really got a hold of me
do you have any do you have any inside
do you have any ideas does anybody
you know any ideas
yeah
is it about
just a
maybe a genetic
disposition to addiction for you or is
it somehow self-worth comes into play
and
you know the the mental strain of
you know everything losing your brother
and and being a parent and growing older
as a female and all these things
combined
put you in this situation
I really
I really believe it's both
I really believe that
all of that comes into play I really
believe it does
and
I'm sure there are people that
deal with similar things that don't ever
become
you know intravenous opiate addicts
and that's cool
but
um I I'm sure that it
that those are absolutely major risk
factors
because I know in my case
um I can't rule either one of those
things out
I believe a thousand percent
that a genetic predisposition has
contributed in some way
I know that it has you told me it was
your uncle your brother oh yeah both
your parents are alcohol both my parents
but you lost your uncle those are my
brothers I lost my brother I lost my
brothers my children's uncle
yeah
my brother and and he was only a couple
years younger than me we were oh man
oh I see you're true that was my he was
my
healed my heart
man like
it just honestly he was one he was one
of the types of people that
um
you hear people talk about someone once
in a while when they pass away
and and you know
they're talking about somebody special
like just everybody who has something to
say about them
tells you how incredible they were and
oh wow you know he was the type person
you just walked in the room and just
every commanding attention to everybody
you just everybody would be laughing or
he would just you know come in and the
whole energy is his Spirit was so
every single person even people who
didn't get along with my brother in his
life
when he when he died
um
would say things like this about him you
know he's truly truly
missed like his absence is really felt
um all the time every family gathering
every everything
um where you might have an uncle or a
brother or a son present
um
we all know how much we're missing out
because he's nothing
and
I believe that for him too it was the
same thing I know that he had some
trying things that he didn't know how to
cope with
and for him and I this is just our best
you know
albeit unhealthy coping mechanism this
is just what we for us what helped us
feel the best and cope the best
as far as how we felt but not only that
I know that for him as well
that predisposition to these things
because you can't you you can't convince
me that all five members of an immediate
family
are gonna have some sort of addiction or
another
and it just happens to be just
coincidental what do you tell your kids
about their future
yeah
and it worries me too
sure
um
I one of my children right now is of
drinking age already
and
you know two two of them two of them
smoke pot
sometimes
one of them more than the other because
she's older and very independent and I
recently had one of my girls expressed
to need it
she's thinking about going and getting
some getting some help to
um get a handle on her on her drinking
habit
that she's worried
that she might be over indulging
and she
doesn't want to
wind up with a bigger problem
so it worries me a lot
um
and I yeah and I I have made them aware
that
this is a genetic
thing that can be passed down within
families and that's
all of their you know responsible
habits and their
you know their smart decision making and
you know they're good choices in making
friends and all that
put aside uh they can still be affected
by it and that they need to be mindful
you know I make I make an example of
myself I try to really put the spotlight
when I talk to them about this stuff put
the spotlight on me
in a way that you know reminds them
what they don't want now because they
don't want you know how they don't want
their kids to suffer or anybody to
suffer the way that they're suffering
because of me
yeah so there's just guilt everywhere
this is built all around
yeah that just makes it even harder
and that just makes it even harder oh
yeah yeah oh yeah yeah oh then then it's
a
uh it's it's a little more of that
weight you know a little more of um
shame and guilt that you'd like to numb
yeah a little more that you'd like to
numb it down it really it I was just
talking to somebody about this
um
a friend of mine last night was telling
me we were talking about this this man
who I I had a relationship with for the
last couple years
and um
this just
ended I guess or I'm trying to accept
the fact that it's ended when I talk
about him
which I do all the time
I talked about him to people I still
call him
to call my husband
um
it just became too much for him too
because you know it's
it's hurtful to watch somebody almost
die and spend 14 and a half weeks in the
hospital
and then get discharged and five days
later be shooting up heroin it's hurtful
to be worried about them constantly
dying or what may happen to them out on
the street
um or to have people coming up to you
and saying they think that your your
girlfriend is is prostituting herself
because she's
her movements are odd and she's going
from door to door in the hotel or
whatever and when really I'm just that's
like or this that's the most way out
[__] I've ever heard that's a really
far-fetched from my world which is like
upper middle class Suburbia but to him
who you know he's
in his 50s and he's from you know inner
city Chicago and
um when when you move like that it
equals
selling yourself whereas for me I man
I'm just going I'm not gonna I'm trying
to find out who's got what I need
I'm sick I need to get well
who has my medicine
you know but that it all became too much
for him and um
and um it all added up to work out for
me
you know
um
last I saw him I left him he came down
here to support me
and you're staying with me in the
emergency room I was I was withdrawing
and boy did it hurt and I said I need to
go to the hospital
um I need to go to the hospital I can't
take this anymore I can't take the pains
too bad he said okay baby I got you
it's like you always would and
you know he died in there scoot me up
and called The Uber put me in the back
of that car and just had means lap the
whole way they're petting my hair and
telling me I you know I can do it I'm so
strong and he's so proud of me and all
that every anything he could to try to
like build me up to get me to feel
myself like I could do it you know
and even that wasn't
um wasn't enough you know I still in the
face of this monster I just felt so weak
I mean I felt so weak and we were
waiting in the emergency room in the
waiting room and we waited and waited
and waited a few times I even told them
like please
get me a doctor I'm afraid of what I
might do I'm afraid I might hurt myself
this pain hurts so bad I just wanted to
stop
and then
I
couldn't do it anymore and he got up to
go check on his charging phone
in the Next Room
and I
dipped out
I was wearing his jacket and everything
it's it's I know right
and you got to remember
we're we live in Sacramento so
I mean he never
been down here before
and you know we were in Long Beach at
the hospital
he didn't know
where he was
when he realized I left he didn't know
where I had went I was wearing his
jacket because I was having you know it
was I was going hot cold hot cold it
wasn't well
I didn't realize I had his
identification
his credit cards
you know his everything in his wallet
inside of the jacket and um
man I just took off and
per usual with no
care about being mindful of time or
anybody else's
feelings and
um
I never did get the fix
I never did find what I needed
but I I found a spot in the dirt
somewhere in Long Beach where I just
found
myself too exhausted to go anymore I
just I couldn't find my way back to the
hospital
and I was so sick
I'm not having the drug
and I was tired and I literally just
laid down
a way down in the dirt
jacket and I fell asleep
and you know by the time I got back all
of him again he was already on his way
back home to Sacramento
and that was the last time I saw him
um
so talk about guilt I'm just really good
at just
giving myself like serving after serving
of it
the crazy thing is like I know how to
stop that
but I can't seem to do it
I really can't
and yeah
and we're talking like my kids
I mean what more is there like
there's nothing I love more on this
planet than these three girls you know
they're just everything for me
they're like they're like my breath
you know
and I thought I was gonna marry this guy
I really did he was incredible to my
kids
he's pretty beautiful too
and you know we had similar interests
and
that's it that's all over
and I'm just left with making memories
and regret you know
it's like I don't know how to do
anything nowadays that doesn't just
um leave me feeling regretful
I did just a couple of days ago
take a step in the right direction
and
um
I called
my home counties
Medi-Cal insurance office
and I asked them
about doing treatment down here
and
they confirmed what I had heard before
which was that
um
in order to get anything other than
Emergency Care outside of that County
where it's my home county I have to
switch my home county to wherever it is
that I'd like to get that care
and that includes for treatment rehab
so I did it I did it
but that's all I did like like I I did
that I switched it like okay well now
well you know
I guess now I'll just you know get up
the nerves to go to treatments
that doesn't take very long
now I gotta figure out am I gonna um
am I gonna just let them watch this
and
you know hear the truth that that I've
been down here but I haven't really
gotten any help yet
or am I going to
what am I gonna call them first and give
them a heads up
all right Amanda thank you so much for
sharing your story
yeah yeah wish you all the luck in the
world you're gonna need it
[__] you're telling me
well I mean hopefully we'll speak again
and
um I really really praying that by then
I'll have a
a different different scenario to
describe to you A better ending to the
story yeah you get the fight of a
lifetime
yeah
take care of yourselves everybody
love yourselves and and love the people
that love you and
make make good choices you only have one
life and it doesn't have to be so hard
Everybody Hurts
it is going to be painful no matter what
but it doesn't have to be so hard so
just I just want to tell everybody that
all right Amanda thank you very much